[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
احتفالات النادي باللقب قناته على يوتيوب
طرحت اغنيه احتفاليه بعنوان هذا العميد
متاكدين وواثقين من نجاحنا ما هي ان شاء
الله فتره محدوده وننهض ونوصل للعالميه
باذن الله تعالى المستقبل بالنسبه لنادي
الاتحاد مستقبل ان شاء الله الجيد ومزهر
بفضل الله تعالى وحاولوا قوته
[موسيقى]
ادل عنيد
بكل روحه
من
يوقفه
من جديد
[موسيقى]
هاشتاق المباراه والدوري السعودي ودوري
روشن كلها طبعا
فيديوهات الاحتفالات ماليه المنصات
وللامانه ما في احلى من مشاهد احتفالات
جماهير الاتحاد بفوز العميد عشان ننهي
فيها حلقتنا اليوم انا اترككم مع مقتطفات
منها والف الف الف مبروك
للاتحاد وانا عود والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله
في امان الله
[موسيقى]
ايه الناس الحلوه دي
جايبنا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
يلا حيوه
يالله
وصل يلا حي
[موسيقى]